joining me now is former british army
officer and head of intelligence uh
mckenzie intelligence services louise
jones good to have you with us let's
talk about that eastern flank with
russia
what could it look like for nato if
finland and sweden join yeah so to
understand um how big a move this is we
have to really look at the history of
nato it was formed after world war ii uh
predominantly focused on the countries
of germany france uk and of course the
us are very much western europe focused
and the main aim was to counter the
soviet union now following the fall of
the soviet union in the early 90s the
baltic states of estonia lithuania and
latvia they applied to nato membership
pretty much straight away
and
countries like finland and sweden which
had maintained quite a lot of neutrality
throughout the cold war they decided to
carry on pursuing those policies now
although nato and finland and sweden
have worked together so finland and
sweden are part of an enhanced
opportunities partnership with nato what
this means they'll do joint exercises
and then the joint expeditionary force
which is focused on baltic security
but really they're looking at the events
and you have to
see where they're coming from which is
that when you look at ukraine the
differences between ukraine and the
baltics very similar history of their
relationship with russia the reason why
there's now a russian active military
operation ukraine and why there's not in
the baltic boils down to really one
thing that is nato membership
therefore the deductions for them is
clear they now want to join nato in full
so
let's also bring in the uk's new pact
with sweden and finland
in particular
is that the perfect excuse do you think
for president putin to intensify his
campaign and
i mean i've been discussing it earlier
as you know do does russia even have the
capability and capacity to
open up a new front there so this will
be a this is going to be a bad day for
president putin this isn't what he
wanted at all um the neutrality of
finland sweden really suited him it
meant he could focus in on on further to
the south in countries like georgia or
ukraine um so but really there's very
little he can do now you know the horse
is well and truly bolted um so he he
doesn't have the resources they're all
focused down in ukraine there's very
little he'll be able to do on the board
with finland um where there is some
maneuver room where he'll seek to try
and use this is in his information
operations so what he's been trying to
do all through this conflict is show
that uh this has been caused by nato's
relentless expansionism east nato has
obviously counted that in saying well
you know these are sovereign democratic
states who actively apply you know nato
has not forced anybody to actively apply
however
with finland and possibly sweden now
joining russia could use this to further
strengthen their narrative which is
having some reception elsewhere in the
world you know particularly with states
like china and it could be used by him
in that way
um and and as we've said about his
resources so um the majority of his
combat capability has been really
focused in on ukraine he's taking some
heavy losses uh he's having to mobilize
units reconstitute broken units he
really doesn't have any kind of military
capability that he would be able to
project the finnish defense force you
know they've been ready for years for
this sort of thing they're very focused
on on protecting that land border
they're very well equipped well trained
well well-drilled there really are an
adversary that president putin will not
be keen to take on unless he's fully
prepared
understood louise jones thanks very much
indeed